you're what yeah make it that much save
it for you [ __ ] me feed me feed me
company me away people
all right so now I'm recording there's
Carmichael and so the camera is locked
in one spot no matter what I do you stay
there there you go
preheat huh today we swap out our
Walmart walkie talkie for some
heavy-duty radios a friend Andrew from
Phe Radio is here and he's brought over
some awesome and motorola radios Andrew
thank you hurt Michael tell us a little
bit about what you brought down here
today because reliant L you look pretty
advanced the waterproofs and proof much
better range better audio clarity and
longer battery life so these are
essentially toys and compared yeah can I
get out on the police Channel since
these radio you could yes if I can make
it sound like a police radio
but you'll sound effects and whatnot
wait like yeah are you saying that the
police have those sound effects for no
reason mainly to let them know when the
conversations over
yeah you don't have to say over on the
police radios it automatically does that
for you in movies whenever they say over
on the police radio it's just like
redundant how radio works
so limbs perspectives radio frequencies
are essentially will let you see light
hits the electromagnetic spectrum and
these just transmit electromagnetic
spectrum in a specific wavelength and
that will give you data
the FCC allocates a certain spectrum for
public for family use and an assisted
expert for business industry and then
another powerful police you what do you
say we text these bad boys out I'm
totally down for testing these now
there's one
we're having a real meeting
not one of those stupid makeup like
these ones like if you stand there and
it's like you ever something or a
shooter whether really efficient meeting
like we're in hey this is like wearing
it tissue dude let's one general thing a
pop singer
I hate to be water over but you know
those are the wedding with my camera
taking pictures appeals to field apart
I'm going to run straight a little pull
my good are you good
[Music]
so the important part about this shot is
seeing his body and his but shooting the
West
atomically correct spider-man
anatomically correct Slenderman
I mean I'm really grateful I mean that's
pretty true yeah I feel like the eyeline
of the butthole is off take it you want
to buy it gym membership I mean I am
spider-man
when you me
I'm pretty big man just hanging in there
I hope to accomplish building a great
short funny short I hope you guys laughs
yeah come closer
yeah
Zach going through techniques for a
shooting web figure this out right now
figuring it out we got this one we got
to like plastics rain we got the like we
got the I'm trying to work on the lake
do was act
we shoot one want me to handle it they
call me Robin says I'm Baskin hey kid
you want to buy some gorgonzola
[Music]
you want to come back to my place proper
vitamin hey kid all right notify 401k
like for quick sale action
my nickname
yes how long have you been running PhD
radio for about a year and a half now I
started getting into it I thought it was
like a market for it a lot of people
were just using these yeah and they're
complaining about terrible audio
terrible range I asked them why they
wouldn't get these and they basically
said they didn't really existed or they
thought only police use them for selfie
- do you need to get in committee
senator let's take anything except for
consider a of the I see you looking at
me right now I don't think it will go
directly into camera injuries you're
talking rent on his way now to see how
far you can get before either is one
wheel dies or we lose connection and
hopefully both in which case his phone
will also be dead in which case w what's
your status
red none red nine red nine are you alive
you should read it
that's a yeah read nine we can hear you
but we're going to go to the rooftop
because I'm losing yet Ren you're so
crispy up here that I feel like salmon
Eric from so crispy media are just
hanging out with us
you are loud and clear red nine keep
trucking if you have him fly through the
hearing here Ren from the future thank
God recognize hey listen guys whatever
you do don't let 40 come back in repeat
it hello that's 42 bag you're ready make
sure you won't thank you this is a
corridor shirt you can give them the
corridor source links and description
you guys want to visit our store so you
guys won't see a cool piece of
technology as technology progresses
little by little you get machines that
can do what previously cost thousands
and thousands of dollars to do in this
case we have a gimbal now if you haven't
heard of what a gimbal is basically
machine that will download something
motor motor motor these three motors are
all in different axes so basically as I
move my hand around these motors will
counteract and they can keep the camera
locked off in one position hand held
shops will give the impression of a
human being holding the camera which at
time is what you want but a lot of times
not the right mood for your piece a lot
of times you want to watch it as it's
you're an omnipresent being look at God
staring at these characters experiencing
their lives so those kind of shots need
to use either a tripod a dolly crane and
the thing is up until this point
scarrans have been super super super
heavy now we're reaching the point where
these kinds of cameras at the new gh 5
or the a 7s because our orphis sony a7s
they're reaching the point where they're
starting to borderline edge into movie
camera quality territory in about one
more year all right
about two more years recording the
Carmichael these cameras will be about
as good as our very first scarlet that
we got back in the day
and considering the size ratio and the
weight ratio in the cost ratio that's
nuts
so it's a little Gimple like this being
able to just sit back well I want a
dolly shot gotta this is the Zun crane
and I've never actually used a gimbal X
before sorry now Shawn Michaels hand
holding his camera and I'm I have this
on the gimbal here so we can compare how
they look over the back I got a head
standing around and on my lapel just
talking into a radio or ready to hear
something coming out of a radio legit
feeling red nine if you get any trouble
in skid row make sure you switch over to
the police
even though probably most business my an
alien horsemanship
hornish copy of that red line are you
somehow possessed by an alien or have
aliens taken over your mind in any way
red nine right what the hell going on
red nine what the hell's going on out
there
give me a status update damn it hearing
I haven't helped I don't know what's
going on we're getting a lot of
interference yeah right not even hearing
that red nine did you say the 6th Street
bridge is entirely gone
has disappeared there's nothing concrete
left over there's no evidence of rings
over here over oh my god these factors
won't have the best of us yet ma'am
have a shot of whiskey for me brother
her down oh I don't feel so good right
now
we're
oh whatever you do don't let 42 back in
forget it
[Music]
you can also this is an same thing
stop that drama betrayal
violence treachery all these and more
the new trouble in terrorist town the
game unknown click on the link on the
screen for more